vous vous avez vous travaillé dans le
milieu artistique à paris vous avez
assisté une trentaine de concerts et
cérémonie de michael jackson à travers
le monde et vous avez été invité à
neverland par le meilleur ami de michael
jackson c'était le 9 mars 2003 vous
aviez alors quel âge 22 ans 22 ans 2 ans
alors vous avez dormi là bas vous étiez
donc vous n'aviez que vous aviez 22 ans
et vous dites que vous n'avez rien vu de
bizarre là bas non alors en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que j'ai dormi donc
avec johanna ma meilleure amie on a été
invité par franck cacher le meilleur ami
de michael jackson d'accord est en fait
il s'avère qu'on était au même moment
que gavin kevina rizzo donc qui a
témoigné
voilà un nom qui a porté plainte après
sa carriole plainte contre michael
pendant donc le procès de 2005
alors donc en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que au début on a fait des
magasins de magasins de jouets on en est
sorti avec michael pendant des heures et
tout ça après on est rentré à neverland
on a passé toute une nuit à jouer à ea a
mangé un everland et tout ça mais quand
donc et après nous on a témoigné au
procès pour montrer pour dire que gavin
arvizo par exemple n'étaient pas
séquestré un événement quand on dit mais
quelle il avait des bons avocats
oui mais en fait il accuse michael
jackson de certaines choses comme la
séquestration de gavin par exemple donc
voilà kevina rizzo qui ici et là il
était très très bien avec michael la
donnerai être victimes de pédophilie
c'est un être séquestrée non vous
concevez ça fait une charge
c'était encore je veux dire c'est que je
tombe la séquestration que l'acte de
pédophilie tombeau d'abus sur un banc
n'existe qu'en ville laval
kevin laval avait accusé michael de
l'avoir séquestrée rue donc bien sûr
entendons-nous sur des faits qui ne sont
pas contestées personne ne conteste
qu'il dormait avec des gamins de 7 ans
déjà
moi je trouve que cela pose un problème
maintenant si ça pose un passé à
l'internât du lobby franchement moi je
vous pose un problème côté malsain quand
même déjà dernière base d'accord je vais
vous dire quelque chose à l'oreille six
mois j'ai adoré michael jackson j'adore
michael jackson j'ai vu michael jackson
en concert religieux à mourir
non non on commençait à douter non non
mais rien à voir
pour moi c'est toute ma vie je n'ai vu
partout et tout ça et après une fois
rentré à neverland
je croyais connaître michael jackson en
tant qu'artiste et tout ça j'ai vu un
ado j'ai vu un enfant
d'accord ça fait tellement j'ai
halluciné sur la différence entre le
michael jackson article sur scène et le
michael jackson à neverland
c'était vraiment un ado et ça ça
correspond au syndrome de peter pan
mais je pense qu'il ya deux catégories
quand je vous entends et quand j'entends
jacqueline qui défendent aujourd'hui
encore michael jackson je pense qu'il ya
deux catégories
il ya sans doute les gens sincères parce
que ils considèrent que c'est le plus
grand artiste musical de série temps
mais il ya un sujet de faudra border
jacqueline même si la question je vais
vous poser c'est que plus l'image de
michael jackson est en train de se
dégrader plus le business est en train
de se dégrader pour michael jackson
donc moi la question et j'aimerais vous
poser puisque vous êtes vous avez été
productrice de michael jackson
vous avez sans doute noté que la vente
de ces cd depuis la révolution la
révélation du document 2h bio sont en
train de s'effondrer
la veille le streaming des chansons
michael jackson est en train de
s'effondrer
ça veut dire que l'on comprend bien et
janet jackson sa soeur n'est pas monté
au créneau pour défendre parce que elle
elle a eu une carrière d'artiste et l
adisq à vendre donc ma question est très
simple
est ce que vous défendez michael jackson
parce que vous estimez que ce type est
encore digne d'amour et d'amitié où vous
défendez parce que vous avez peur que le
business de michael jackson s'effondre
d'abord la question je la trouve
ridicule en ce qui me concerne pas ce
que j'ai je m'adresse à une horde
utilise des cigarettiers
je n'ai rien à faire avec ces cds je ne
suis bien sûr je m'adresse à la
production sinon moi je produisais des
concerts malheureusement il est mort et
peut-être qu'un jour quand moi je serai
là où j'aurai la chance encore de le
produire
la professionnelle non mais c'est pas la
poser non si je pense que mme jacqueline
n'a pas compris ma question si
normalement ils parlent pas ils parlent
pas que productrice française mais comme
professionnel delà de la vente de
disques et les parent concerné c'est
celle ci mais bon franchement la
question eric question important mais
non celle du business en question de 80
on est en train d'analyser la autres
non c'est vous qui me la posent non mais
c'est bon on s'y remet deux heures à
poser la question de la musique à deux
heures du matin